with daruma i know you're launching a
crowdfunding on sedan spark in october
of this year but did you also try to get
a production company
we've talked with a couple people we've
had interest i mean we've had a lot of
people come to us to say this is an
amazing idea
like i love this who are you casting as
the leads and then when we say that
we're actually authentically casting the
disabled
you know our two disabled leads
enthusiasm fizzles because again
you've got to look at what translates to
to box office sales so
it's so much easier to attach a name
actor to a script
i mean especially something that's got
you know these challenging characters to
play
um but i don't want to compromise the
vision
of this project like the intent of it is
to not
the intent is to to be a vehicle and a
platform for
for underrepresented voices and i i want
it to be the first of its kind i mean
can you
name another movie like this well i
can think of where there's been named
actors that have played
disabled individuals right but not um
no it's very rare to see except for
dodgeball sorry
i mean they did have well i mean people
with i don't know if they were
autistic or what different you know but
dodgeball had
very true but you know it's it's very
rare to come across
something completely new and this is a
story
that has never been told before and
especially in the way that we that we're
wanting to tell it
so that in of itself is very unique and
that's not something that i'm willing to
compromise on which is why we're going
the hard route and we're doing this
ourselves
what roadblocks have you run into with
daruma in terms of
you've presented it to production
companies other things maybe that we're
not aware of
i mean i think that's the problem most
indie filmmakers running into is
financing
so where do you get the money from like
how how do you how do you put this into
reality
we've done three different budgets we've
done one in a million we've done it half
a million and then we've done this
bootstrap one that we're going to be
crowdfunding for
in october um you know there's
there's challenges with every project so
first of all like is your idea good can
you get it on the page can you
articulate it
can you start finding people that
believe in your vision
um this has been something that we've
been working on solidly now
for the last three years and we're right
now
at the point where we we feel like we've
gotten
our platform and our village of people
and supporters together and we're ready
to
to take the next step and attempt to
raise the funds for production
um but again you know this is this is
something that every
project runs into is who comes up with
the money
so what are you learning from these
obstacles
well one i'm learning that nobody is
going to do it for you
you have to be able to do it yourself
you have to put yourself in
uncomfortable
positions and be prepared um
you know if again if you're not good at
pitching then you need to
to become good at pitching you need to
to learn how to tell your story you need
to learn how to tell your story
succinctly
um you know i'm also learning to
celebrate the small victories
just because you know you don't get from
a to z
immediately you can't neglect every step
that goes in between you know like for
us
getting uh our cast attached our amazing
cast attached that was a win that was a
celebration
then getting our our film uh our
proof of concept shot you know we while
we were doing that the woolsey fire was
going on
we lost a location actually we lost a
couple locations during that because
we were going to be shooting up in agora
hills um
and we ended up we we called in a couple
favors and begged borrowed and steal
our stole it was terrible english it was
terrible
and we big bored and stole um but we
ended up getting
you know some new friends along the way
who helped us but it's very important
and
actually a friend of mine a friend of
mine told us to be a producer a friend
of mine
when i won the contest it's very
important to
celebrate the small victories um when i
was at usc
i had a professor amazing on camera
professor named joe hacker
and he would coach young actors you know
how to
uh go about their career and
he loved to tell the story about when he
was younger and he was working on
broadway and he went up to his
idol and was like you know i want to be
where you are how do i get to be where
you are
and the response was you can't but there
are a million ways
and he always liked to tell us that you
know every small thing every small
success
was one pearl on a very long strand
so you just have to keep threading the
needle and finding the courage
and the strength to keep going great
story
what does it take to get a hollywood
movie made i don't know i haven't made
one
um i imagine it takes quite a bit of
luck so
um do you want to make hollywood movies
i feel like they're
i have some scripts that i've written
that are that are certainly more
commercial
than the ones that i have um you know
i'm working towards
but i think that as a young screenwriter
you know
starting out it's very important to
establish your voice
and your brand um it
you know i have a lot of fun projects
that i don't spend my time working on
are developing because i'm not there yet
you know those could be the
quote-unquote hollywood movies
i feel like at this point you know i'm
proving myself
and i'm i'm you know putting my work out
there and i've got to put my best foot
forward and
you know maybe a hollywood movie isn't
the thing that i want to build my
platform on
um i'm not looking to make a quick block
you know i mean don't get me wrong you
know
being paid for writing is awesome when i
got my first check as a writer i was
i took a picture of it because it was an
incredible feeling
um but you have to consider that you
know you're in it for the long haul
it's very easy i think for a lot of
people to burn out
and if you can find your voice and your
passion and the things that keep you
drive you know keep your drive going
that will sustain a career does it scare
you to write
non-hollywood movies no because i find
that that's the thing that i
i tend to play in the most i mean where
i'm emotionally at my head spaces at
the thing that scares me is writing you
know science fiction
and things like that because i feel like
maybe i don't have the imagination
to come up with the world you know of
this maybe a post-apocalyptic or
something maybe i would be very afraid
of doing something cliche
how do you top star trek how do you how
do you top star wars you know and who
who am i to even try
but again you know we go back to the
point great storytelling isn't about
these set pieces it's about the
characters
so if you look at most science fiction
pieces they're actually
stories about political turmoil or
refugees or something like that so
again go back to character go back to
your story
you